what's going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and today we have a lot of new details
about Guardians of the Galaxy vol 3
including a major plot point about Adam
Warlock Empire magazine just came out
with a new article entirely based on the
Guardians of the Galaxy and in this
article they interview most of the cast
and crew where most of them talk about
how this is the end some of them say
that they could possibly return but some
outright state they're done now we know
that some deaths are most likely coming
in Guardians of the Galaxy Vol 3. James
Gunn has really hinted at this and this
new article not only gives us a lot more
information about the movie but could
possibly give us some hints as to which
characters are dying and which ones are
surviving plus James Gunn also talks
about what the real meaning of this
movie is what it's really about and
pretty much states that this is the end
the article States at the end of the
film gun promises years-long near
narratives will be resolved even if not
everyone will make it out unscathed
James Gunn says it is a Trilogy the
first movie is about the mother the
second movie is about the father and the
third movie is about the self that is
the overall story and like all good
stories it has to come to an end so that
is only a part of this article as you
can see this article is giving us a lot
more insight on the Guardians of the
Galaxy Vol 3. and we just get a lot of
awesome details about the movie so let's
go over the entire article and break it
down if you love Marvel and want to stay
up to date with the MCU be sure to
subscribe and if you subscribe and leave
a comment down below you enter our
giveaway for a chance to win a PS5 an
Xbox series X some Marvel Legends or DC
items the winner gets to choose and we
pick a winner at the end of each month
so like I mentioned this exclusive
Guardians of the Galaxy vol 3 article is
coming from Empire magazine and the
article is titled a-hole's end game now
this is a direct callback to the very
first Guardian of the Galaxy film where
we are introduced to each individual
member of the Guardians when they are
captured by the novacor corpsman day
says they call themselves The Guardians
of the Galaxy in which denarian Saul
then says what a bunch of a-holes I'm
sorry
I I didn't know how this machine worked
what a bunch of a-holes
transport all four to the Kiln now one
thing that this article really really
articulates is that this is the end of
the Guardians of the Galaxy James Gunn
States in this article that the
Guardians of the Galaxy franchise is a
Trilogy three movies and he's done and
some of the characters if not all are
done as well now some of you may have
caught at the last Comic-Con the
Guardians of the Galaxy cast were all
crying big time and when asked about
that this is what James Gunn had to say
he said well this third movie is much
much more emotional but then we have
this other story of this group of people
who made each other's careers at the
same time he's referring to the cast and
crew of the Guardians of the Galaxy Zoe
Saldana specifically said in this we
grew up together in that respect none of
us were big stars when it started out so
right away this movie is indeed going to
be a lot more emotional than the first
two and that is most likely due to the
fact that one this is the final movie
for this cast and crew or at least most
of them in two some characters are most
likely dying and a lot of people are
really looking at Rocket Raccoon right
now and honestly it could go either way
he could die in this film or he could
survive and get somewhat of a happy
ending in fact they kind of go on to
talk about this they mentioned that
James Gunn was fired this happened after
Guardians of the Galaxy 2. some old
tweets came up that he apologized for
and then a bunch of people had his back
which led to him being reinstated as the
director and writer of Guardians 3. and
James Gunn was really relieved for many
different reasons but of course one of
the biggest reasons he said was the
Guardians of the Galaxy franchise this
Trilogy has always been about Rocket
Raccoon it was always about finishing
Rocket's story and he said that one of
the biggest bummers about being fired
from the franchise was that he was never
going to be able to finish Rocket's
story and here's where the Empire
magazine article starts to give us a
little bit more details than we already
knew about Rocket's upcoming story in
Guardians 3. the article States you can
see the sea needs of Rocket's Ark from
day one in the original Guardians
there's a moment where quill notices
some strange metal mechanical markings
on Rocket's body neither character
exchanges a word about it but as blue
swedes Hooked on a Feeling blast on the
soundtrack it hangs heavy with meaning
this Furious little furball clearly has
a dark history
Thoughts From You Girl
then James Gunn states in the article
that is one of my favorite small moments
in any of the Guardians movies it's so
brief but it gives us so much quill
takes it in and understands that this is
a lonely creature that's the joining
factor of all of the Guardians that
they're all orphans in a way then James
Gunn goes on to State this Guardians of
the Galaxy vol 3 is not about saving the
universe it's about the Guardians saving
themselves the article States in
Guardians 3 we will see the gang unearth
Rocket's tragic past to discover how he
was the product of a gruesome experiment
by evil Cosmic scientist the high
evolutionary who created a menagerie of
hybrid creatures on a planet known as
counter Earth a Suburban facility of
Earth the high evolutionary is one of my
favorite Marvel villains as James Gunn
I've always been a big fan of 1932 film
island of lost souls he he's like a
space Dr Moreau he's a destable
character frankly and they go on to talk
about the high evolutionary and Adam
warlock's connection but let's finish
talking about the end of the Guardians
first before we jump into that the last
part of the article goes on to state so
is this the end then certainly for this
iteration of the team it feels like
Chris Pratt says I wouldn't want to rule
it out speaking about returning but then
he says he feels really comfortable with
the way it's wrapped up if he never came
back then it states that Dave Batista
has definitely said he's done with Drax
calling Guardians of the Galaxy vol 3
the perfect exit and I think a lot of
people really think that Drax is going
to die especially since his daughter and
wife have died already he could go to
whatever afterlife that he believes in
and be with his family or finally just
be at peace because he clearly was never
truly at peace without his family Palm
clementiff who plays mantis says that
she is not against returning at some
point but she also states that every
word that I I said as mantis was written
by James Gunn so we'll see and of course
James Gunn is done after this movie it's
the final Guardians film for him and
he's going over to run DC Cameron Gillen
says it feels like we're closing a
chapter Karen Gillen says well never say
never however this is where it gets kind
of interesting Sean Gunn James Gunn's
brother who plays craglin also does the
stand-in work emotion capture work for
Rocket Raccoon and he straight up says
that he is done and he says this is and
I quote my swan song as Rocket meaning
he's done after this movie and listen to
what James Gunn said about possibly
returning or the Guardians of the Galaxy
continuing without him he said I would
love to see any characters that remain
at the end of the film get solo movies
or join the Avengers or a new version of
the Guardians or whatever but that
specific line that he States I would
love to see any characters that remain
that means some aren't remaining meaning
some are gonna die so this is the end of
the current Guardians of the Galaxy team
as we know it now new characters might
be joining I got a Morlock and we have
some very good details about Adam
Warlock The Sovereign and the high
evolutionary to go over right now as
well because I do believe that by the
end of the film Adam Warlock will most
likely be good and whoever's left with
the Guardians he might join them and
we've got a major reveal about Adam
Warlock from this article as it states
the high evolutionary is also
instrumental in the origin story of
another character one Adam Warlock Adam
Warlock is an incredibly powerful
artificial super bean and in this film a
supporting character that James Gunn
says has a very specific connection to
the high evolutionary and they actually
talk about how Adam Warlock is going to
behave and think in this movie Will
Poulter who is playing out of Morlock
stated that Adam Warlock is going to be
in his infancy phase he States Adam
Warlock is coming in as a young person
entering the world trying to develop his
moral compass there was a lot of comedy
in that but also some genuine pathos
some dramatic meat on the bone and that
part right there about the moral compass
is very important as well as what they
said about him being in his infancy so
basically he's going to be born and
Aisha is sort of going to be like his
mother so he's essentially just going to
do what she tells him to do which is
going to be go and capture Rocket
Raccoon now they also say that he has a
very important connection to the high
evolutionary very specific connection
and if you've been following the channel
I've been theorizing about this for a
while I think that the high evolutionary
has actually created and is in charge of
the Sovereign The Sovereign is a very
evolved species in fact they say that
they don't even procreate anymore they
simply make their beans well this is
pretty much what the high evolutionary
does and this is pretty much what he set
out to do evolve creatures not just
animals but humans as well so I've
always been thinking that the high
evolutionary would have created The
Sovereign and this could be how Adam
Warlock gets to be under the control of
the high evolutionary because the
Sovereign is under the control of the
high evolutionary and both Aisha and the
high evolutionary want Rocket Raccoon so
both are going to be using their
creation Adam Warlock to retrieve rocket
we know that he gets captured but we
also know like they mentioned that Adam
Warlock will be discovering his moral
compass so I think we're gonna see sort
of a progression in his story arc
throughout the movie of him kind of
being like a little baby just listening
to Mom and Dad however he goes on to
realize that Mom and Dad aren't exactly
good and these people that he's trying
to defeat they're kind of good so I
think that conflict is going to be a
pretty big moment for Adam Warlock in
this movie until eventually he realizes
hey High evolutionary Aisha they're bad
the Guardians they're good they're the
Guardians of the Galaxy they're trying
to save the Galaxy and do good I need to
be on their side and I think this is
eventually going to lead to Adam Warlock
being a part of the new Guardians of the
Galaxy team whoever that may be it's
clear that some of them are going to die
and some are going to be remaining who
those members are going to be your guess
is as good as ours so let us know who
you think is going to die and who you
think is going to live and the comments
down below don't forget to like the
video and subscribe of course stay up to
date on the latest MCU news and
interactiveaway you can always follow us
on Instagram and Twitter as well and as
always thank you all so much for
watching woof woof
thank you